It is essential that our two regions
cooperate. I will
mention three examples: first, the
conference on climate change in
Paris in December, second, now also
to define the post-2015 development agenda,
third, the fight against
drug trafficking, organized crime and
corruption, we celebrate the dialogue that
is being held.  Cuba with the US and
we hope that our friends and brothers
from Cuba and the people of the United States
resolve the historical problem they have
had. We must know that the
European Union has a voice and an expression and
has an enormous and infinite desire
to help  in venezuela human rights
and democracy are not disturbed and
we have the right to say it and we have the
right to say it because we are here
we are politicians for this